we're back with the hilarious kim
whitley and finesse mitchell
i am just having so much fun and uh
there's something that ross is going to
tell you about that is really doing it
for me and we're going to do it and i'm
thrilled well this is so exciting i saw
this actually my fiance wellington
showed me this i was like i sent it to
the news team we got to try it it's a
new party game for you and your family
people posted a video of the funniest
family ever look playing a game where
you have to get a cookie from your
forehead to your mouth with no
hands look how hard this is and they're
dry like that
you gotta wiggle it down so we have some
cookies
that's made me laugh so hard so you guys
want to try it yes all right we have
some cookies here all right hit the
music we can do this
[Music]
[Applause]
and you don't get to eat it in color
man
[Applause]
man
[Applause]
did you get it
[Applause]
you have to try this at home it is so
hard to do
drew you got this you got it
just flip it
[Applause]
go go go go go
[Applause]
i believe in you
i believe in you
[Applause]
oh my god please put that on espn
that has to make sportscenter top 10.
i have to say finesse i don't know if
you heard him but he said that was more
exciting than the super bowl i have to
agree that was the best thing so thank
[Applause]
[Applause]
mitchell please let's do this again
[Applause]
[Music]